US Olympic Committee late Thursday said the behavior of swimmers Ryan Lochte,...
...James Feigen, Gunnar Bentz and Jack Conger was not acceptable...
...nor does it represent the values of Team USA.
The USOC statement acknowledging the group was involved in an act of vandalism...
...came after Mr. Lochte's public account of being robbed at gunpoint Sunday...
...was discredited by Rio Police.
Mr. Lochte subsequently changed details of that story,...
...saying the robbery happened at a gas station rather than on the road.
But surveillance camera footage appeared to undermine his account.
Police said armed security guards have detained the group of gold medalists...
...after at least one of the swimmers damaged property in the gas station's restroom.
They were released after they paid about $50 for the damages.
A lawyer for two of the swimmers, Mr. Bentz and Mr. Conger,...
...said his clients didn't understand why Mr. Lochte had claimed they were robbed.
The crowd booed the two swimmers as they made their way to the airport...
...after a judge granted them permission to leave Brazil.
The athletes later boarded a flight to Miami.